An evil robot babysitter, a 75-ft
shark, and one of Spider-man's
biggest enemies! These are the sci-fi
films you don't wanna miss in 2023!
One of the most highly anticipated movies
of 2023 has got to be "Dune: Part Two," the
follow-up sequel to 2021's massive adaptation
of Frank Herbert's science fiction magnum opus.
Both "Dune" and "Dune: Part Two" come to us from
critically acclaimed director Denis Villeneuve.
The man who's no stranger to sci-fi, having
created incredible films like "Arrival" and
"Blade Runner: 2049." "Dune" is the story of
a royal family in the distant future that is
exiled to the remote desert planet of Arrakis,
which is home to everything from the enigmatic
native Fremen, giant hostile sandworms, and a
precious interstellar resource called spice.
Because of the massive nature of
the story from the original book,
Villeneuve decided to break his films into two
parts to do these characters justice. "Dune:
Part Two" will continue where the last film left
off as audiences will follow Paul Atreides and
Chani as they lead a revolution of the Fremen
against the planetary occupation of the evil
House Harkonnen. The lead role of Paul Atreides
is played by Timothée Chalamet. The supporting
cast of top-tier acting talent included Zendaya,
Rebecca Ferguson, Stellan Skarsgård, Josh Brolin,
Dave Bautista, and Oscar Isaac in the first
installment alone. In the upcoming sequel,
the cast has gained even more star power.
Joining the cast are Florence Pugh, Léa Seydoux,
Christopher Walken, and Austin Butler hot off
his performance as Elvis Presley in "Elvis".
Following in the footsteps of sci-fi horror
movies about artificial intelligence such as
"Ex Machina" and "The Terminator" comes
Gerard Johnstone's "M3GAN." The story
follows the creation of a seemingly perfect
robotic doll that is supposed to serve as an
ideal friend for kids and even a possible
babysitter for parents. But soon the evil
android begins to take on a mind of its own.
The most obvious comparison for "M3GAN" is
to the other iconic horror franchise featuring
an evil toy, "Child's Play." There's even been
some online beef between the Twitter accounts
for both Chucky and M3GAN to hilarious effect.
"You should probably run."
"M3GAN" is the brainchild of Akela Cooper
and James Wan, the latter of which has become
well-known for his work on franchise fare, such
as "Saw," "The Conjuring," "Fast and Furious,"
and "Aquaman." Since it's produced by Blumhouse,
the production company which has backed every
Jordan Peele film to date, this movie brings back
Allison Williams, one of the leads of "Get Out."
It also features the talent of Violet McGraw,
Ronny Chieng, Brian Jordan Alvarez, Jenna Davis,
and Amie Donald as the main characters of
this horror flick. Since its January release,
M3GAN garnered a lot of attention with a viral
dance scene and a staggering $30 million opening
weekend at the box office. You won't want to
miss this strong start to 2023's sci-fi roster.
Hot off the heels of their recent Holiday
Special, it's almost time to check back in
with everyone's favorite team of multi-species
interstellar heroes in this year's "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3." With James Gunn back at
the helm of the series he created back in 2014,
Marvel has allowed the Guardians to have
one last hurrah with the finale to their
trilogy. Part three of the series brings back
all the main stars from previous appearances
including Chris Pratt as Starlord, Zoe
Saldana as Gamora, Vin Diesel as Groot,
Dave Bautista as Drax, Bradley Cooper as
Rocket, Karen Gillan as Nebula, and many more.
Taking place in the far reaches of space
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" continues where
the past two films left off following the ongoing
story of this unlikely superhero team. It also
requires some knowledge of movies outside this
series to fully understand what's going on,
since these characters were deeply affected
by the events of both "Avengers: Infinity War,"
"Avengers: Endgame," and "Thor: Love and Thunder."
For example, the original Gamora was killed by
her adoptive father Thanos during the infinity
war and was later replaced by an earlier version
of the character from a different timeline. Since
Starlord and Gamora were developing a pretty
serious romance, this new dynamic will surely
play a part in the next installment. It's also
important to know how much drama there was behind
the scenes regarding James Gunn since he was fired
and, subsequently, rehired throughout production.
"Autobots, roll out!"
That's probably what at least one giant
shape-shifting robot will say in the
next edition of the massive "Transformers"
franchise. It seems like only yesterday that
audiences were watching Shia LaBeouf stumble
around big GCI robots back in Michael Bay's
2007 "Transformers" adaptation. Now there
are six mainline movies and one "Bumblebee"
spinoff for fans to enjoy. Paramount Pictures is
continuing the story with 2023's "Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts" which will function
as a sequel to "Bumblebee" since it takes
place sometime in the 1990s with all new
characters who've never been seen before.
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts" is directed by
Steven Caple Jr. It stars Anthony Ramos, Dominique
Fishback, Luna Lauren Vélez, and Tobe Nwigwe are
the human characters who discover the transformer
robots on an archaeological excavation. This
film also features a star-studded voice cast
for the various Transformers both good and evil.
The list includes Peter Cullen as Optimus Prime,
Pete Davidson as Mirage, Sebastian Maniscalco
as Wheeljack, Ron Perlman as Optimus Primal,
and Michelle Yeoh as Airazor. "Transformers:
Rise of the Beasts" is directly inspired by
the "Beast Wars" era of the original toy line
and tie-in animated show, which establishes the
Everdeen and her climactic struggle against
the oppressive government of the Capitol.
Although there was a satisfying end to the
series for many fans, it should come as no
surprise that producers at Lionsgate wanted
to bring the franchise back to life with some
kind of prequel. These movies did make huge
amounts of money at the box office, after all!
Well, that's exactly what's happening with 2023's
"The Hunger Games: The Ballad of Songbirds and
Snakes." This film is a prequel directed by
Francis Lawrence and based on a 2020 novel
by original author Suzanne Collins. It takes
place nearly 64 years before the events of the
original "The Hunger Games" film by focusing
on the early years of the Hunger Games event.
Lucy Gray Baird, Jason Schwartzman as Lucretius
Flickerman, Peter Dinklage as Casca Highbottom,
Viola Davis as Dr. Volumnia Gaul,
and Hunter Schafer as Tigris Snow.
"I want every camera watching."
Another year, another highly anticipated Pixar
movie. The legendary computer animation studio
is back at it in 2023 with a movie that's
been shrouded in more mystery than their
usual projects. But "Elemental" got audiences
excited for what's to come through a recent
trailer that revealed some information. It's
no secret that Pixar loves taking abstract
ideas or concepts and anthropomorphizing
[an-thruh-puh-MOR-fai-zing] them. They did
this with emotions in "Inside Out" and souls
in "Soul," so it seems as though "Elemental"
is continuing that trend by portraying
various natural elements as people.
"Elemental" takes place in Element City, a
metropolis where all the elements of the world
live together in harmony as conscious beings.
It will feature groups of little elementals
based on fire, water, and land as they interact
in an urban environment. It sounds similar to
Disney's 2016 film "Zootopia," but with elements
instead of animals. The story itself will focus
on two elements: a fire woman named Ember
and a water man named Wade as they become
unlikely friends despite their natural
differences. Its official synopsis from
Pixar itself goes into more detail about its
on-screen dynamic. The description explains,
"The story introduces Ember, a tough,
quick-witted and fiery young woman,
whose friendship with a fun, sappy,
go-with-the-flow guy named Wade challenges
her beliefs about the world they live in."
"Elemental" is directed by Peter Sohn
and stars the voice acting talent of
Mamoudou Athie and Leah Lewis
as Wade and Ember respectively.
As if "The Meg" wasn't big enough, it's gonna get
even bigger with "Meg 2: The Trench." This sequel
follows up on 2018's over-the-top sci-fi action
story about a 75-foot ancient megalodon hunting
a group of scientists out in the Pacific Ocean.
This sequel continues the story of rescue diver
Jonas Taylor as he must once again deal with
this pesky megalodon at even lower depths than
before. While there's little information out
there about the plot of "Meg 2: The Trench,"
it's safe to assume that the plot involves both
another megalodon and possibly even a trench.
"The Meg" was a surprise box office hit back
in 2018, making over $500 million worldwide
off of a budget of only $130 million despite
a generally negative critical reception. The
first film only managed to snag a 46% score on
Rotten Tomatoes from critics and an even lower
42% score from audiences, and yet somehow
it did well enough to warrant a sequel.
Regarding the choice to make another "The Meg,"
Jason Statham himself explained the reasoning
during an interview with Entertainment Weekly
during the first movie's press tour, saying,
"I think it's like anything in this
day and age — if it makes money,
there's obviously an appetite to make
more money. And if it doesn't do well,
they'll soon sweep it under the carpet
— but that's the way Hollywood works."
Yet another superhero movie on this list is DC's
upcoming "Blue Beetle" movie, which will bring the
iconic techy character to the big screen for the
first time. For those who don't know a lot about
the character, here's a quick crash course on
everything you'll need to know. Blue Beetle is
a superhero, whose real name is Jaime Reyes, who
gains powers after a blue alien scarab attaches
itself to his spine. Because of this event,
he can form a protective exoskeleton around
his body at will which easily allows him to fight
crime. Basically, he's DC's answer to Spiderman.
"Hi? Do I know you?"
"Blue Beetle" will be directed by Angel Manuel
Soto and features a mainly Latino cast. The actors
include Xolo Mariduena, Bruna Marquezine
[BROO-nah mark-ah-ZEE-knee], George Lopez,
Belissa Escobedo [beh-LIH-suh es-cuh-BAY-doh],
Adriana Barraza, and Damián Alcázar to name a few.
In fact, this is the first film within the
DC Extended Universe to have a Latino lead
character at all, which is a big milestone
for the franchise. In an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter, Xolo Maridueña
discussed how essential the Latino
background of the character and his family
was to the history of "Blue Beetle," saying,
"With this character, he lives with his
family and there's no way to hide who
he is. Right from the very first moment he gets
his powers, his family knows. That's different."
Would it surprise you to learn that even
more superhero movies are coming out in
2023? Of course not, there are so many
of them that it would be bizarre if there
weren't at least four per year to watch.
That being said, the upcoming "Kraven the
Hunter" adaptation differs in many ways from
the other sci-fi superhero flicks on this list.
"Kraven the Hunter", directed by J. C. Chandor,
is a collaboration between Columbia Pictures,
Sony, and Marvel to continue Sony's separate
cinematic universe of movies like "The Amazing
Spider-Man," "Venom," and "Morbius." It
will star Aaron Taylor-Johnson as the
larger-than-life character of Kraven the Hunter,
a dastardly big game hunter who has often been
a dangerous enemy for Spiderman throughout the
comics. During an interview with Comicbook.com,
Johnson went into detail about what kind of man
Kraven will be in his solo film, explaining,
"This is a character that was built ages ago
and it's in a new time and era, but yeah,
is he going to be the hunter that we
all want to see? Yeah, absolutely."